Let's go next to our color from the two oh
three area code.
We're trying again I guess with Connecticut.
Maybe we'll have better luck this time.
Who's there from two oh three.
Hey, it's Ali from Connecticut.
Hey Ali, what's going on?
A a this one is just lighthearted.
Um, I was just wondering about your, how to
videos.
Um, I was wondering if you get, if you get
annoyed when people like goof on them or would
you rather like hide them?
No, no, I don't care.
I was 20 years old.
I produced a bunch of how to videos.
I started in some of them, everything from
dog training to uh, basketball to, I don't
even remember what else.
I was like the, a recipient of a massage and
a massage.
I don't, I don't care.
It's fine.
I was 20 years old.
I was making more money doing those videos
than any of my 20 year old friends were making
at the time.
And a, it was the start of getting into audio
visual production.
And it's, it's funny, I don't mind that at
all.
Would you, uh, would you like do any more
as like a goof?
I mean listen, maybe as a goof, but it's,
I'm pretty busy right now.
I don't know that I'm looking to do instructional
videos.
Um, but sure.
If the right situation presented itself, I'd
be in an instructional video again.
Why not?
All right.
Last question is really short.
Are you going to be at the Boston Street Pride
Parade?
Oh, a when is it happening?
It has it even been approved?
I thought it got blocked or something.
Yeah, I think it's scheduled for the 31st
of this month.
Oh No, wait.
Oh, I may go and check it out then and interview
some people that, that might actually be interesting.
I didn't realize that.
Alright.
Thanks for having me.
Okay, I'll leave from CT.
Appreciate it.
Thanks for the call.